all right and we all love the last word
with Lord Candido and I bought this
Friday morning campfire man and uh
normally man I'd be like aw like simply
energetic and crazy we still energetic
and we still hype but uh it's a lot
going on this week right it's a lot
going on and um never leaves you to say
the least right so me you have some real
real good discussions and um just
everything that's going on right now in
the world and stuff like that and I
definitely appreciate the phone call you
made and we had a lot to talk about you
know obviously we know what's going on
in the world today we know what the
climate right now tensions are high
people are down people are up you know
but I'm gonna give it back to you
because um you said a lot of things that
resonated with me and I really really
appreciate that so let's just get to it
man just get to it I mean I've watched a
lot of things recently many upset in a
way that hopefully the world doesn't
forget but I just kind of worked on
something yesterday so I wanted to read
this to you guys and all I can say is
here we go it would go baby let's do it
so basically I'll just start at the top
before we get started today I wanted to
say it wrote something I wrote with
regards to the events currently
happening in this country
here we go everybody strap in strap in
baby there's something deeply wrong with
the way many of us live our lives and we
can no longer pretend to be ignorant or
turn a blind eye to the blatant and
painfully widespread racism towards
black people in the United States of
America this problem runs so deep that
many of us that call ourselves Americans
might need to ask ourselves what that
beans this country was founded on a
principle that all men are created equal
and yet from the beginning we were
hypocrites the peep the black people who
live in this country have faced racism
slavery inequality and have been treated
as inferior people for centuries for no
other reason than the color of their
skin do they have lungs that breathe the
air the same way white people do yes
they have a heart that pumps blood
through their veins yes
do they have a brain that is capable of
so many amazing things yes but somehow
each black person in this country has
faced a different journey in life that
has been filled with fear angst and
desperation at every turn
this country is proud to use the word
freedom fairly liberally as something
important to its core values we have
thought wars to protect that very idea
in those Wars there have been both white
and black soldiers many of whom have
given their lives and yet for those
black soldiers who survived and were
able to return home after seeing the
awful acts of wartime and have been
scarred by images of death and
destruction did they get to return home
to America to enjoy their quote freedom
no some went back in to save Li slavery
for the men of which they just fought of
war some faced insurmountable inequality
at every turn and that feeling of
freedom was just a fleeting idea lost a
persecution lack of opportunity and fair
treatment
tell ourselves that as a country we have
made progress over the years and decades
that things are getting better but it's
clear from recent events that they are
most definitely not
the video that many have seen of George
Floyd a man whose life was taken from
him by a white police officer who
literally crushed the life out of him
slowly and painfully for more than eight
minutes is atrocious what that officer
did was unforgivable
and I do hope he is punished to the
fullest extent of the law but there is
still a bigger issue surrounding that
video and it's the lack of action by
everyone else around him the video is
shot by someone who watched a man die
without doing anything to stop it
the other officers over the course of
George Floyd's slow death chose to
ignore his pleas for help as he was
running out of air all too often we
choose to do nothing and that choice to
avoid confrontation and forced people to
change and do the right thing cost him
and the rest of his days on this earth
the idea that any person deserves to
live their life more than any other
person just because they have a
different color skin is unconscionable
black people in this country have every
right to be treated as equals and should
be by all of us not just some we now
have to be better than our forefathers
who founded this country as a white male
I have zero understanding of what it's
like to be a black person in this
country but I do know wrong and terrible
actions when I see them we cannot sit on
the sidelines any longer it is time to
band together as one people fighting for
equality for our black brothers and
sisters so that one day our Constitution
might be something we can actually live
up to so whether is voting for the right
person in office will help push these
issues to the top of the pile to try and
be fixed or donating to many different
foundations and organizations that can
help in ways that we don't even know
sitting idly is no longer an option
so please do all that you can so the
black people of this country can one day
say that freedom is a sorry almost made
it
freedom from is a value of the American
people and they are proud to say it
because one day it might be true no
doubt no doubt
um lucky that was beautiful um me you
have talked for hours and um I want to
say first of all brother I am so proud
of you I am proud to call you my friend
I love you you know um since I met you I
felt we had a kinship and these are the
reasons why you know and coming from you
you know the it really it truly
resonates you know this is something
that I've been dealing with like I told
you my entire life and a lot of people
from color I've been dealing with our
entire lives and it really really helps
to hear all of us come together and not
accept just lip service or corporate
hashtag or whatever but the reality is
everything that you poured your heart
into us coming together this is part of
the process for enacting change
and it has to happen now I mean this
this has to be a moment where we look at
this moment as a watershed moment for
America and obviously to now in that
change so that are the future
generations our sons our daughters they
don't have to go through that you know
so you know obviously I don't like to
get too political a lot of my platforms
and stuff like that but obviously this
has been weighing down on us and the
only thing I will say is um I've also
been doing some educating myself you
know and um guilty of maybe to worry too
much at the top level as far as
political stuff and systemic you know
police brutality that needs to be
changed but also were looking at the
local level I want to thank a lot of my
writers on Lords of gaming down there
specifically Josh reading me and him had
similar talk how I've had with you and a
lot of it man is just what your day is
like yo man what can I do to help right
what what what can I do and the main
thing is just listen like listen
empathize we're all human beings you
know I'm saying we all bleed the same
color blood and um we will get through
this we will get through this but
overall strategize mobilized educate
yourself everyone that's listening you
know and um we will get through this and
we will make change happen I'm firmly
this feels different than any other time
you know I'm saying so he again thank
you for that thanks to chat for
everybody for listening you know I'm
saying you know we didn't wanna get too
preachy but you know we definitely
wanted to say what we've been feeling
and we'll be a suffer because it's been
it's been it's been a rough couple of
weeks
I said you know yeah it's but as I said
it's like from my perspective I have no
point and I've heard it said out there
and it was one of the things that
probably just makes it the simplest
piece of like understand a simplest way
to for me to understand that I have
absolutely no clue and it was just a
very simple idea that one person says
and it's the exact same for me if I'd be
it pulled over for a speeding ticket all
I am was annoyed that I potentially got
a speeding ticket what's this gonna do
to my driving record or my insurance not
the fact that somebody who sees lights
behind them and their feel for fearful
for their life that every every time
that happens
and that that is
I never thought that way yeah yeah and
that is well I guess was gonna say
that's just I'm not gonna say it's
willful ignorance it's ignorance because
it's there and it's just one of those
things that you don't think about but
it's it's like you this very sad and
unfortunate moment has hopefully opened
a lot of people's lives or eyes to see
that not it it's not the same out there
exactly exactly and like you said you
said it beautifully I mean all the
weight comes down to raise empathy right
you know even if someone doesn't fully
understand or doesn't fully you know
have gone through the experience you
know obviously as a black man yes I've
gone through it but it's empathy and and
that's that's the thing a lot a lot we
have to a lot of people have to shed
that lack of empathy because they're
holding onto certain things you know
that's really not important what should
be important in human life what should
be important is you know saying stopping
police brutality and making things fair
so that people have to hear to law but
um look man
like I said I I can't I can't have said
it any better and you said it and we
will get to it we will get through it
and what the cool thing about dizzy what
I like is that another thing that we all
have besides the fact that we're
brothers were humans we also have gaming
we got common bonds right that that
bring us together and that's what I like
you know it's one thing I respect about
the last word and what we do and I
respect like a said respect to call you
a friend and a brother and we will get
to it we gonna get to it man but thanks
for sharing thanks for listen everybody
to check oh yeah yeah yeah he he hits me
to me I was I was holding it up too he's
a special guy he's especially God I had
to tweet it out after our phone
conversation you know you doing that you
know it resonates brother
it truly does man so thank you and uh
let's have some show let's have some fun
it's like the mood a little bit deep
don't let these times be for nothing yes
make sure you find a way to do something
yeah whether it be donating you have
black lives matter there's a lot of
places out there lots of things lots of
website
yes and yeah just just don't make this
nun be for nothing
I just a week this is a moment that
can't be missed also if anybody needs
resources and just you know I'm saying
like any information please you don't
hit us up I could send you links on this
a beautiful documentary I'm actually
watching right now it's called um brown
eyes and blue eyes experiment by Jane
Elliott it's excellent from from the
young level you know just from from kids
how it just chose to show you how things
are instilled and um man like a lot it's
a lot of stuff brother yeah I will put
the links up he's got some links in
there I'll put some stuff in there right
now as well just educate you know that's
the main thing educating itself so that
we can understand how to tackle this
thing man
but um yeah that's what I got but um
apparently some things also going on in
the world too today
yeah in the world of destiny at least so
we are gaming podcast so we were gonna
transition back to what you guys came
for but just like anything else silence
isn't an option so absolutely it's been
an interesting few days in the world of
this game and it's also been weird I
listen to DCP last night and they said
it as well yeah it's kind of weird time
to want to be excited about something
like this yeah I was like but in turn
looks like as you guys have hopefully
seen on Twitter or not a company that
makes this game holy behind all of this
stuff going on and just like the
the people that work there that they are
completely behind the email I don't know
if you saw the two-word joking email
that was forwarded around and all of
that stuff they're one of the good ones
so yes it's it makes it it makes a
little easier to be like alright I can I
can support this one exam as a little
we've been getting a lot of teasers Oh
have we with regards to mm well it
started last week literally during the
podcast and we got this creepy sound
wave picture yes oh yes right and
gillard nature mm-hmm and that's where
it start and we're like all right and I
like hey it was the 12 said make sure
you watch the Bungie Twitter and we're
like okay podcast in the morning like
weird alien SMR like creepy creepy
noises happened and then it's just been
kind of ongoing for the week of little
teasers that they're dropping cinematic
happened in game
I honestly sometimes forget is still
even like some of its in-game someone's
on Twitter I'm always like which side is
which I'm trying to remember the order
of the days because Wednesday was so
Wednesday and Thursday were the two
cinematics and then Tuesday I guess at
reset was the first one with Jupiter
correct yes hmm
so in chronological order after we got
the
audio tease tuesday star do when we
logged in in game and it was elite
cinematic to someone had seen but we
just didn't talk about it that much but
it is kind of the Sun on Jupiter's like
part edge and you see the planet
rotating and as the little like ominous
tone comes in a little pyramid ships
like pops in the last couple seconds a
very distinct sharp edge like triangle
just like the pyramid ships that we've
seen oh no that already got me basically
recording a video on Tuesday to say why
is there a ship by Jupiter when iris
Newton's wall shows they're barely in
the world of orbits and again there's a
joke coming up and just have to blow
past it they're inside Uranus so
but yeah I mean you go Neptune for like
proximity to the Sun you go to Neptune
yeah they crossed over that one they
made it to Uranus and then this week
they were like one ships like light
bright sighs inside of like two that
free space between Saturn and Uranus so
the timing of them making it to roughly
Saturn making it between Saturn and I'm
just I can't even say it anymore but
that's the problem so yeah so yeah but
yeah the timing works that they're
pretty much going to kind of end this
season at about pattern basically yeah
we kind of thought that that was like
the light bright spacing and they seem
like they're gonna get roughly there
well my first question is why the hell
has RESP uten not shown us this little
guy on his wall cuz yes they're outside
Saturn and this is leaking at URI at
Jupiter so I know I will set it we need
to send a drone to your a morning so we
started serious cuz that has been thrown
out the window extra set behave I see
you yeah like the first thing is like so
what does that imply is we've got a ship
that resp you tonight or can't see I
means we're in the world of space magic
I'm like cloaking you never know it's
like it sounds stupid but it's like
never know if it's like a scout type
ship or something that's like I'm right
I'm close enough to the planet you can't
make a distinction between me like who
knows but he's not all the Damned look
like that ship is not on the pyramid
that wall I don't think you're right so
it's a good point do you what do you
even think that does that even matter or
is it just like a cinematic teaser like
the rest of these things no no I think
there's significance I think their
significance because at the end of the
day you know Bungie has been specific
about highlighting
with the dis Arif the bunkers and stuff
about you know where it's at now I know
trams he's saying he doesn't feel it's
accurate
he said because when repeating was
talking this volatile again show more
shifts closer um I will say this the
reason why I'm leaning towards your
theory kind of where you going with it
is that I feel that in order to set up
the eventual DLC right
yeah the false because we go we gonna
get into it we got trailer talk it's
like leaked anymore it's all official
yes it's all official now so I always
got this feeling like they would send an
emissary first like a like a scout or
like you know them say that's always the
question is what's on the moon right
because here's the thing here's the
thing when we end guarding the salvation
spoilers if you ever ended it by now
yeah yeah nine months later already come
on now I gotta talk about it but you
know the thing is this like their whole
thing was not to be initially combative
with us the thought the thought process
was like yo you you know could be like
you know don't join I join us almost in
a way like don't don't necessarily look
at us as the enemy you know I'm saying
we can be great being you together kind
of a bit almost like a forsaking the
light look at what we could give you I
mean I'm saying almost like what you've
been lied to in a way so I would feel
that before coming to obliterate us
yours in that they would be want to
negotiate right now obviously the little
that make this storyline could set up
and then you know we go at them and
whatever what have you but I definitely
think that maybe there's a reason behind
that particular set up like we are going
to deliver the terms to you now if you
don't comply see that this this is where
this score could be fired and I hope I'm
not over guessing it you know say like I
hope you don't say bungees really in day
bag with this cuz they not they have to
knock it out the park me we all agree
season it aware these last couple of you
know this hasn't been up to season the
worthy review is not gonna be getting
high
Mark's not could be up to stare so I
would like that man I would like that
Chris says they what the guardians I
mean what better tool for darkness than
one crafted by light yeah I think I
think we're in this possible negotiation
phase once they get there by possibly
that one ship like what are you what do
you think I was like unfortunately it's
a video game and we have to shoot stuff
yes in theory it would be cool yeah it's
like baby you come to the negotiation
table and they don't even care cuz then
they're gonna like you know take you out
right there type thing red red wedding
moment of yes false peace but yes
it's weird because
like the darkness in the light the union
yang the traveler and we don't know if
it's the pyramid ships and that is why
that could be a question is there
somebody in my twitch chat even said is
there a greater force that the pyramid
ships may at some point like want to
help us with or is there a weird light
coming - well I mean that's and that was
the mention of like Sabbath oon being
two years more powerful and all this
other stuff of lightning infinitely
growing like if the pyramid ships are
not related to her row she is still out
there as the looming over five celestial
got to a point late where she's it she's
the biggest and most powerful hmm though
and then the other question is or are
these pyramid ships just the giant ruse
and not anything that we expect is it
something completely different
now when you say completely differently
different from the darkness well like
everybody expects like the veil most of
people expect a veil by the like
silhouette covered statues and yeah like
that's you know it seems fitting but
it's like a giant curve ball or
something and these workmen ships on the
same as the pyramid ships in the mood or
they are but they're not I don't know
like yeah I'm very much in the dark but
like it would be cool if they just throw
a giant plot curve ball like didn't see
that one coming digitally I would like
one of those moments of like oh damn
they went there
see I'm different though we got to talk
about these DS trailers and I'm gonna
tell you I'm going you know so Tuesday
was the Jupiter trailer and more update
as well mean almighty was bigger less
lots lots bigger in the Sun in the tower
space so we know the almighty still has
to get resolved now what day that's
gonna happen
i my honest suspicion is today now I
don't know but it's usually when server
like tix kind of update between trials
and sir
like there's enough things that happen
at this reset they'd be like and
whatever's gonna happen go like do all
that stuff at the same time seems
fitting and if not today then my hunch
is honestly gonna be is it gonna be that
like 9:00 a.m. Tuesday or like
the name before or I don't know if it's
not today I'm honestly old for clueless
so yeah but it still has to blow up
right it has to happen I think we we are
in agreement that it happening on reset
in conjunction with a new season might
be too much so yeah feels like it gets
lost at that point yeah I'm feeling like
yo we gotta get it like today you're
saying like I would say you know
something something the cinema or
something because um what if the
Almighty is the next season that might
ease out of here man it this this has
gone on long enough it's like I think
it's gonna get blown up there have been
rumored leaks spoiler warning for like
10 seconds 3 2 1 of damage to the tower
so yes at some point late something may
like graze the tower and but we don't
know the other implications of that
we've joked about it before anyways
whatever but mmm at some point Rasputin
has to do his thing yeah we think that
was the whole point in the season yeah
fire upon the Almighty it's not small
somebody also mentioned either in my
comments somebody said they eat Almighty
is like powered by a black hole I'm like
I have no idea if that's true but it's
also legging it's got enough power to
suck up the energy of a sign is what it
was going for right right right
so it's got some ginormous power source
or mm-hmm if a black hole is able
whatever it is it's like it's pretty
large so I was like maybe it's like the
by exploding the almighty we unleash
some like thing and that thing just
actually does explode in peace of the
almighty go everywhere who knows well
but it's gotta happen in a couple days
at a minimum
like today tomorrow Sunday Monday like
there's only for real options left so I
will be definitely watching very
intently in the tower like as I said my
surf videos gonna be delayed so if you
guys want to see if it's the build like
delay to their cuts today mommy
streaming at about noon looking up in
the sky so I think so too because also
when we've been logging in you know I've
been talking like the music has changed
everyday like it's a miles change yeah
I'll change it's just very ominous
something's happening about to happen
music yeah so you know I anticipate
extra session text ready job
don't do it today is gonna be
overshadowed by reveal of it later on
yeah that's how I feel right so like
let's get it today you know knock it out
you know whatever whatever if we have
debris great if we don't you know we'll
see and then cuz to me Tuesday is new
season and it looks crazy is which we
gonna find at least like we don't know
the neighborhood like this is really
strange so let me go get me gonna get
into them some people are honest ly
wondering like as its redacted yes what
in just in a business say mm-hmm how do
you think this is going for there are
some people who are very connected
obviously you know medium chat mini and
Twitter who follow Bungie are excited
there's people who don't give to you
know Jeff's about Twitter and their
dislike
what's coming next haven't heard you
know websites talking about it none of
this stuff is like IGN doesn't have hey
here's the next expansion here's the
trailer we're covering these are the
features nothing and they're just like
what what what like more already the and
then it's like the people of the season
pass they're gonna get it anyway and the
people who are gonna do the individual
season by they actually can't buy it
until the season goes live well I mean
on a business side I don't know if they
have that much to lose because they
season people are already there and then
people who buy it they're just gonna see
it an hour before they buy it right but
that hype is gonna be ultra high if
they're like all sweet by like this do
you think it's a good marketing idea or
do you think it's risky in any way and
then the other question would be do you
think this is like a one-time thing in
the fall expansion they can can't really
do stuff like this for a bigger
expansion versus a seasoned DLC it was
just kind of curious your thoughts
between how these are going down yeah I
think my gut tells me they normally
don't do this let's just call it what it
is right they norm we by now would have
the name of this season at minimum that
has been the cadence that's been the
pattern my gut is telling me the reason
why they are not telling us the name is
because it's probably so closely tied
into possibly what's coming next season
that it's like you know like some names
are just a dead giveaway okay I think
maybe this is one of those situations I
get they tell us like oh this is what's
happening yeah season crypt for example
would be like okay everybody knows what
the hell like and if you guys don't know
the deepest own crypt is on a different
moon not Europa which we'll get all into
that in a minute but if I said they're
like oh dude
this is like it's like one word gives it
away but it is a fitting title for the
season they just don't want to like
spoil it for us like that I could
definitely see and in my weird thing is
the seasons have had loose thread
connections but
we messed with like the time so the
almighty we're screwing with the sundial
so then like all the Saiyans were like
hey we want to change the time one we
lost well one other dude you know
hightailed it up to the Almighty he's
like well okay you're gonna ruin the red
lesion so we're gonna go blow up the
last city okay so the last city's about
to get exploded but we're gonna blow up
the almighty I'm still wondering what is
this in between seasons like yeah so
beat yeah
the connects almighty to this and in the
in question mark to big fall expansion
which we're now seeing stuff about we
have to assume which day which they're
transparent about right that's the
mollies more so transparent but yeah
yeah there's if there's some imagery
yeah yep yeah I was just saying like
this day I've never seen this from them
right there literally promoting
September way more than what's having to
go have it on Tuesday
so again when I see that that denotes to
me that Tuesday is so directly the next
season if directly connected that if
they tell us we are going to put it
together and they want that level of
secrecy they want that level of mystery
too took it to happen now I could be
wrong I mean that's I'm in the exact
same season I have this that have
nothing to do with this then I'll be
wrong
you know Sam but yeah i think i think
it's it's man i can't wait we talked
about it we gonna talk about these
Detailers I'm at the Bell choppin man I
just love keeping you on the edge of
your seat until we're like oh it's like
and then it's like the give you in the
movie Gladiator he's like unleash l and
it's like when they like going to my
almighty jupiter little triangle teaser
ends day twitter starts going at it
mmm first one was little 10 second
teaser of said drifter mm-hmm coming out
of a ship and then leaving and flying
towards a planet moon whatever
and shout out to Bungie because when
they do put things in game maybe they
don't respect to the world of space math
but at least in reference to pictures
they're usually decent about it yeah and
if you look up images cuz everybody's
always wondering like hey rumors snow
planet would have liked the snow moons
that we could possibly go to and there's
been concept art of Europa and then
Enceladus now this don't the deep stone
crypt is on Enceladus which is a moon of
Saturn but it's also a very cleaner lake
the moon itself is like much cleaner in
the like set like in like satellite or
space photos like they have some amazing
shots of these like moons like in
insanely high detail mmm but they look
very very different the Europa one looks
like it's been like clawed and scratched
at or has these rivers and canyons of
like red over an icy planet surface and
that is exactly what it looks like this
ship is flying towards in the little
trailer and then what do we see in like
what looks like a sci-fi movie like
rebreather mask fitting we see The
Drifter like flip a coin and then set
that coin on fire I'm like what the hell
does that beam
so drifter going to basically what
everybody has to assume is Europa mm-hmm
alright that's this is the open can of
worms number one do I'm gonna do the
other one we just talked about in the
other two so then yesterday mm-hm
similar Twitter timeline that's why this
had follow us on Twitter mm-hmm we see
another major character and this was the
our wonderful lady from shadow key we
have nearest slowly trying to crawl her
way across a basically Blizzard covered
planet yeah she's like got the mask in
the eyes you still see the three eyes
it's still her she doesn't have her horn
out because well it's cold tell mm hm
but you see like she's crawling over
like ice and stuff and there's one frame
or two where you can see the ice is
actually like got those like a little
bit of like red kind of veiny energy
mm-hmm and then she's like and then
towards the end she looks like she's
either like doing like some energetic
like guardian thing with her hands or
she's like pushing through like a force
field but yeah like what
so we have drifter going to Europa eros
is long Europa and then you'll start
wondering is like is this gonna be like
The Avengers cast company are we gonna
get like one a day like who's dropping
today like this what's going so those
the two trailers we've got as of 848
Central Time my time this morning I have
seen nothing else yet now something
drops and of coordinating the course of
the podcast well that'll be cool and let
nothing yet yeah I which I think this is
destiny endgame I think this is what's
going on I think they are setting up the
dark this is September listen Luke's
were Luke's westward you are not ready
right you are not ready this is the
endgame finish a straight-up dog this is
the endgame baby like we gonna get all
the major players that have have loose
story threads that have not been
finished and I'm saying eros is
definitely that point obviously she has
a connection with the darkness we just
did shadow keep we found out the pyramid
ship was there it's been there all this
time she's on the next move all right so
she's there drift is the wild card he
ain't with the Guardian business he's
been using it yes also shout out to buy
food we've had on shameless play love I
love saying that by the way I love
though he said you can say that we
everybody that's kind of awesome but
anyway moving focus this awesome is do
sort of thing is like if I remember
reading law with the drifter I don't
know if it was the malfeasance law or
one of the law pieces and I wish by was
a to correct me that he and his crew his
crew they got killed off by certain
figures or darkness he kinda energy and
entities he was the only one that
survived and he was the only one so he
has a familiarity right yeah so we got
him as a player we know how we feel he
feels about the Guardian but he wants to
use her and then we got the whole choice
thing that remember we need resolution
with that choice we still have a
resolution but which side did you pick
the drifter side and sees it at a
drifter right so we got him he's a whole
different wildcard in
we go should I just lay it all out with
you a name would be event as long again
I don't think there's anything else you
can spoil because everything's been will
get obligate weeded right right now
let's get back to the god warlock stand
up let's get to the God now dramatic was
going on you already know it's Osiris
talk time um so here's the day Oh
after season of bringing back saint-14
done right done he was in a [ __ ] he has
a little or piece yep he was in a ship
traveling to God knows where and segura
his ghost was getting worried about
where they were I'm just giving you a
basic summary summary now he's try to
get this information this risky thing
for whatever the hell he's doing
while it's there they encounter what
appears to be darkness like energy in
his ship or what have you to the point
where they think they might not make it
and they're about to die like this thing
is really affecting him he somehow
escapes so he has now encountered that
there is a potential that he could be
going there that's all I'm gonna say
based on that lore piece damn I wish my
folks here cuz even break break it down
when he better to know I'm breaking it
down yes I gotta watch like today Osiris
is in his bag for so yeah he found him a
seed of metallic sorceress Thank You
crystal for helping me cuz I'm
butchering it so that's that then the
mind bloom thing that you sent me today
let's talk about it from damage to - oh
yeah and one word so they're gonna pull
it up so I get it right let's go and
Cain Dillon dmg o for if you guys have
seen him community manager basically
what he states is he says one word and
it's soon that's all he says and then I
know some people have been like digging
back into old destiny lore and stuff
like that and we have begun no time to
explain
and the flavor text on that gun a single
word is etched in two onto the inside of
the weapons casing and all it says is
soon now what is no time to explain
related to sir
get it stuff just you know we don't have
time to explain well yeah it's the
strange baby
it's stranger danger let's go it's time
we have that seen her since d1 the only
information we have now I believe it was
war mine again my Laura's shadi I wish
wife was here to correct me but what I
was in a brand was it right or the
sister we got the connection with her
with the brace right there like the
street or was the sister yes I like that
she's a sister she's a break
she's a break yeah so that for - they'll
see what yeah LC yes was confirmed so I
listen man ain't fooling me that days
there's words that you use and look I
know people are y'all reach it maybe
some people okay yeah reaching you know
I'm saying but I'm not the only five
three tweeted this shot to Paul Tassie's
retweeted is you put this to my
attention a lot of people have retweeted
it is time to know what in essence was
the whole deal with the stranger from d1
what they were preparing that's for and
the whole bit and this is my ultimate
there let's just get to it vengeance
ain't gay let's go that's being game
let's go how I see this thing playing
out is and which should be so fine is
each of the major players and we still
got Mara out there we don't know what's
going on tomorrow
I'll test they had a good one it was a
funny joke but it was the way it was
done because you have Aris with the
covering over her eyes you have the
drifter with the covering over the mouth
will speak no evil see no evil yeah
haven't done here no evil he's like
we're just gonna have Mara show up in
earmuffs and then of course the value
aliens said under it was hilarious he's
like earmuffs only and it's like a hey
this is a family establishment like
everybody's like Mars like if you guys
ever play on Steam know if you don't yes
you'll miss out on some everybody's
jokes
some people like rename their random
character account like Mara sobs right
leg or thigh or whatever just to be
they're so ridiculous but yeah people
like her too yes yes but yes
out there we have Aldrin who we still
don't know about so those two are kind
of a big connection I don't think he's a
major player at the table though no I
don't think it's a major player I just
think that's still an unfinished piece
of story bit unfinished three yes yes
but yeah like Marv is a big one who's
been part of this whole darkness do we
get to see the emissary do we get to see
anything related to the nine late
there's the how big this thing goes I'm
very very curious
Rick stay focused dog stay focused I'll
see y'all with a chat with the we stay
focus on Marcy they're just like Martha
she's hot and what stay focused listen I
think so cooking man I think at the end
of the day we are talking September
avenges endgame all the major players at
the table at at Europe there's something
going on there whether it be the meeting
spa or some discovery and I think this
is the knights of the round table yeah
this is like the unholy alliance yo we
got to come together if we're going to
be we we need all of you all of you have
some level of expertise to deal with
this situation we may not like each
other you know Sam and the whole doll
crystal jumping palm there's Laura about
Mara sending a message via Vance - Oh
sock plant - see ya there's a lot of
people that a lot of them they've been
in cahoots and even even Osiris and The
Drifter to bring Saint back the sundown
of work they had to get some dark peace
or some peace I don't forget what the
texture of it or I believe it was
darkness something involving that he had
to get the Drifters expertise in it
there's a law piece for this and
cigarettes Agera is like yeah why do you
bring him in here right and he's he else
ours like no I need him for his
expertise in to think so all of them
have a connection in a way you know I'm
saying either whether it be to the
darkness or knowledge of the darkness
and they're gonna have to band together
to debt yeah cause y'all has a sell it
like yeah they all oh dami on it like I
think they all not that they are with
the darkness maybe drifter after human
he he
whatever he got to do we we know if
shifted something else just like book
yeah he's looking out for a number one
yeah he looking out for self but I do
feel they all of them are willing to
kind of bend the light to achieve a goal
to get to their goal they're willing to
flirt that gray area between like to get
to the goal but I think ultimately all
are good - we don't know the gesture but
that that's what I'm thinking man and
and I think this is the first wave of
defense a literary thing I think the
darkness is that powerful that this has
to happen and I in my last prediction
I'll say I think state I'm scared
wall outfit I'm scared I'm putting it
out there right now somebody people
dying somebody I'm telling again like
the gravity of forsaken wasn't cave
that's what yeah that's what puts that
story in facts like pretty high level
for destiny yeah
mmm because of the weight of losing
almost everybody's favorite character
whether it was the decision of time
Nathan Fillion being busy or not it's
still the fact that it was a very
beloved character and it was the way he
I mean we don't lose major characters in
this game like that so acts who in this
war whatever who may not make it who is
like he's gonna take a wrong step or
venture out too far as you said like oh
I mean the drifters destiny is
potentially like the pyramids like his
destiny is there and potentially I think
somebody was saying in chatting in mine
yesterday like I don't know if his
destiny is to die because of the pyramid
ships but his like he doesn't want to
see that he doesn't like seeing that
stuff about the pyramid ships it's kind
of crazy only shad is on fire right now
oh the star of Blackwing he was saying
emissary mentioned her in the nine quest
The Forgotten blade eros the tragic
drifter the hourglass estranged are all
coming to where the nine have been seen
before then and I we we got are we gonna
are we gonna deal with are we gonna like
interact with the nine for the first
time on said you know at your home oh is
that where they've been seen is that a
place where that you can like
communicate with them we still don't
know what the hell they are are they
like the celestial bodies that like are
even farther away
in like 17 for I've got where they're
just like toying with the universe kind
of like puppet masters I don't know what
level the nine are right yeah I still
don't understand enough damn we need we
need to get back but okay I still don't
understand we played that card we're
gonna figure it out on our own
yeah we had Churchill but you know it
maybe get mine is going on mother would
be dope and um yeah man what's going on
uh fuel in the pill so I see that david
vitter salute oh yeah I think it could
be I know they're a major factor I
always get the sense for them that we
have to like prove worthiness to them
you know saying that that's always been
when the emissary speaks when you're
doing the reckoning and stuff like that
I always get the sense of like
worthiness for readiness for for
something so and that we gotta do why
eros is there that she is a very
important she's always key two's been
and taken King yeah shadow keep yeah and
now she's in this one the only one
things she really skipped was the
dreaming city yeah let's do our overrun
this way more Oh who's not making it who
who's who's boss acceptable
I could see you know you want to know
one that would actually like make
everybody question themselves
Zavala has ever be like I don't like him
all but he sacrificed himself for he did
something like he if he has a valiant
moment of I'm thinking of a word and I
can't but I was like don't you be like a
self-sacrificing yeah he's like there's
a yeah there's a proper word and it's
just not coming to me but whew but legs
up I mean he would be one that like
everybody's known have been attached to
for a while but tie you to face y'all
went to a deaf stop flavor you do you
what did I know that not even not even
for that reason not even for that reason
just because it would be something
that's it hits home because it's a six
year character it's not a not to be like
hey or and new it's like it's one of
those major pieces and of course I don't
want to you know I don't see certain
characters go but the ones that would
have wait are some of the oh geez yeah I
Cora's the Cevallos have been around the
longest and we lost gained right like if
you've bring you know if you bring
saint-14 and then you kick him out six
months later that doesn't have the same
like weight as Kate who's been around in
the game for six years yeah you know
like I mean if it's one of the two og
vanguards then oh yeah that'll that'll
hit pretty hard for either of them my
core would probably hit harder
August hit hard she's been quiet but
she's pretty beloved I mean one thing
though we do know the eye Cora and Aris
relationship is strong yeah and though
she knows to communicate and she's been
known to sin you know Aris has been
known in the community
i Cora's been willing to kind of bend
the rules to get to an end game why she
ain't she not go on the straight and
narrow all the way but with good stuff
like if she sees a threat she will do
this you gonna use the hidden or you
know Aris or what have you to to get it
done
um I don't know if if my gut is telling
me that the Vanguard
I could be wrong might not get involved
until it's a head-on kind of event my
gut is telling me that the what we gonna
call them the UM I don't say the
unfavorables but like what is this this
ragtime it's like you're antsy heroes
cuz you've got ears
you've got the drifter you've got Morris
off you've got the stranger it's like
all of them are not like hey we're the
almighty Captain America's no these are
your like Wolverines or Deadpool's your
anti arrows of like yes aid for the
survival of like the overall grander
species of everyone they realize hey we
can't just sit on our butt but in the
normally they're like look kind of do
someone doing some of our own things I'm
not really caring about you guys while
I'm investigating the moon
I'm the drifter I'm still powering up my
crazy ship all that stuff like mmm all
those pieces are still mmm like their
own ideas but something bigger bringing
them together is like yeah it's like the
I'm sure there's a very good comic book
collection of antihero people that would
sum it up pretty well but I mean that's
that's what it feels like is all like
Osiris the exiled like I mean all of
those types of people I mean Ana Bray
the firt like I wouldn't call it The
Forgotten but I mean she was doing her
own thing on to do these people are not
like in the general community of
guardians in the tower and the traveler
like they have been working from the
outside and that's like this whole group
äj-- mmm official word by the way group
itch I'm not entirely sure that's a way
though Diana Brown thinks she'll be uh
uh uh what you call it to replace Katie
yeah I don't think she was to be in a
tower like that she's she's kind of a
free spirit plus her connection with
Rasputin is we still need Rasputin on
the home front so I don't see her
getting into that role I definitely
still see aldrin you know I Cora would
hit heart our core would hit hard um oh
wow that done I think we could be seeing
it into the van Gogh I mean hey anything
is possible
listen people going down people going
down the question doubt if it's all well
I don't know if I could deal with this I
don't know if I could deal with that man
that that would hit me hard
you know say that would have a lot of
weight I know a lot of
to talk everybody like hey wait ain't
nobody play no but I mean he's a big
deal but mm-hmm that would put that
would put some weight cuz he's been
happy way he's been an idea for three
years and then we have curse of Osiris
who brought him and when they kind of
raised back up again in our minds and
stuff so uh tease him to bring him in to
remind us of him and then to just strip
him away that'd be that have some way my
only hope go if I don't think yeah
that's not my guess but I it would ya
lose out my guess
Trey trains I agree and he's agreed that
I've got a crowd listen a Cora dying
would hold emotionally yeah there's no
doubt if I Cora goes yeah it's yeah yeah
it's real it's real it's there's no
doubt there's certain characters I feel
she would be able to list um but I'm
just thinking about the unfavorables for
right now cuz I feel that those were on
the front line and I feel like Omar is
too powerful I don't think she's she
would either like sacrifice a galaxy and
herself in it it would be something much
grander than ours
she's as Mars way too powerful I could
honestly see like The Drifter being
involved or him doing some wily scale
The Drifter would be I think Eris has
got too many connections as you said
between her and Mara and all this weird
stuff going on
The Drifter is the one that seems like
the easy the easy out which seems like
kind of a cheap move but also it is his
destiny with relation to the pyramid
ships to like not not come out so hot on
the other hand but so his might he's he
may be going there to try to knows like
I don't know man
this is why these next few days
Tuesday's gonna be big I am going to I'm
off work I'm gonna be streaming all damn
day cuz we're going right into a season
this obviously something's gonna be game
activity wise but the whatever stream or
Vidak that they do mm-hmm
man well I mean well we will we all be
like pulling that over that with a
fine-tooth comb like just digging
through and rain by frame I'm gonna fill
up an entire hard drive of screenshots
yotaka chat is on fire right new rad
loser web planet moon is way too small
you're not ready for the apocalypse that
puts a pyramid on every location toss
out 1/3 of the activities the big rule
I'll shout out the black way he said
right before Korra dies she says see you
see you cookie the tears just like yeah
I I feel that I feel that I've come a
long way with a Korra you didn't say
enough well I mean I've come a long way
with um man I think we go we're gonna
lose some here's the thing though I
think that the stranger needs to be
around because I think the stranger is
my vote that is not good enough that
happen too but she might be coming in do
you think she's coming right yeah okay I
think that as far as I def I don't see
because the cat has been away so long
to kill it off that quickly after the oh
I don't see if she comes in she's not
yeah if she comes in she's not going
away yeah I just thought it was like
because there's people who won't even
know who she is so they're gonna have to
build her they're gonna have to give her
a back story because literally all we
know about her is go here go here go
here I don't have time to explain see a
lake we don't know crap about her in the
first place now we got a little bit of
lore from Rasputin knowing that is the
sister of Anna pray and all that stuff
but she if she's like a time traveling
or doing the southern like there's stuff
going on Shanna Doretta night yo you
might be onto something
cuz I'll have enough gambe today that
could be the way to get rid of gambit
would adjusted I think blower is like an
evolution to era that's how they like
that's the catalyst for like game bit
perfected or whatever they give the the
change of gambit coming to its new thing
when his either demise or passing the
torch or something to move gambit and
the way it works to something I was like
maybe he gives you know the mantle to
someone else to keep doing this he's
like he's gonna die like this whatever
his purpose of linking his purpose of
game and all the power he's
electing for something and if he can't
do it he may need somebody else to run
that whole JEP who knows like yeah you
gotta see shop to scream in a build I
was talkin to scream I have to scream
you squeeze got some wild theories
though oh that is a narcosis scream if
we have you on the podcast we are gonna
have to give everybody disclaimer in
advance yes of the wild spin foil
theories that are coming they're basing
and I guess it didn't listen to like
story time from scream but unfortunately
I will also tell you it's not gonna be a
short podcast that day it and everybody
be like bag yeah yes key scream I will
say one thing but he said scream said he
feel that the saboteur like thing is
tied into um oh man did it like they
almost like to Saturday thought I think
he took like one in the scene so ice
cream was in his bag last night like he
was really going on shout the rat he
said remember his last word I'm coming
home ace those words made me yeah yeah
fax fax fax definitely you know I'm
saying a lot case and a lot now will I
know Tom just got to that part um Kate
was in love with a court yeah but I
think this can't according to you
everyone
I got the feeling it was one-sided I
didn't get there I got the feeling like
you know he respected her he definitely
may have felt away that was almost like
a Dilla tonic love I don't picture that
that way like a car was like you know
his behaves day like I don't think I
don't think said I've never got that
file you don't say
but um yeah yeah we gotta see we gotta
this gonna be fun man I cannot wait yeah
three mom long one to two year okay is
y'all good brother yeah what I would
like to eat I want will be fired to set
up destiny Avengers endgame is I want
like a trailer like this every evil week
or something like one other person
flying out two year old but showing up
on your role for like like for that
meeting like you know as a like that
would be fire well it depends if they
like drop them because we got Tuesday
was the Jupiter thing Wednesday Thursday
you still have potentially if they do it
through the week either
maybe it's Friday and Monday if they're
going for weekdays they don't like pop
stuff on the weekends but if you go
Friday you go even just Monday for two
more
characters mm-hmm and then they might
drop a bigger bomb of you know tuesday's
reveal having one or two more in this
like collection you you like five or six
in there I'm like there's not gonna be
like fourteen involved but oh I think
five or six like would be a pretty
amazing cast to see yes like you have
the tower social space with legs of
Allah and The Drifter will drift that's
a that's a thing like hmm are we giving
a new social space
because if the drifter leaves bro oh
yeah trying that's right I know they
said where they're eventually working on
us getting bounteous but story
interactions are talking to him if he
literally is like headed to Europa
he can't just like magically be in the
tower like think about that you're
absolutely right so cuz basically even
though this is a future season this is
technically happening in real time right
so in theory these characters I follow
yeah that's what I'm saying right well
so I put it this way Tuesday well we
should log in is eros gonna be on the
moon is is the drift they're going to be
in the tower
oh is this super foreshadowing that is a
good that is a question
yeah but the gem is the time was weird
because I mean just said like there's a
ship by Jupiter in her speed and can't
see it he's that at ease of like what's
coming or is that more because I mean we
see Aldrin wake up under a sheet nothing
happens like a few days later he doesn't
like strolling on the next like reset
has been so long so again are these like
like why show all of this now oh I know
I know believe me that's why I'm
wondering like is there a new social
space in the fall
could be I mean right now we have the
farm mostly useless use um we have the
tower the obvious one like do you think
of new for what do you think of new
social space actually serves a purpose
or is it more way to like put like Story
characters in like the you know a Europa
base or something or have it makes sense
because they all freaking flew there or
is like do you want to fly to another
and I think that like hopefully they
need to get the bounty is from orbit
face if there's the news ocean space cuz
I don't want to go between all these
places trying to pick stuff up for my
days days tasks to me the social space
is kind of overrated I've never I mean
they they okay I mean listen this is
what they need
I want a cinema weather and I wanna a
good sized cinema of all these
characters on screen interacting
debating going at each other that
necessary is like a motley crew like
this crew is not all the way live but
they understand what they gotta do all
for today thank you brother and I'm
saying they serve s testify care for the
intervals might do for at segment listen
you know yeah all right he's gonna gonna
build a video style yeah listen I need a
nice ten-minute 5-10 minutes cinemas
with all of them and each one trying to
put their philosophy all hottie she deal
with the situation or take authority
like I want some real Laura walks and
everybody gets silent what I was like
ask you to but I gotta get back to my
table because bungees not gonna do that
it is and then we go get mad they didn't
do it and we've all wasted opportunity
so I'm gonna regional all just been
boiling back here at ups but first why
do we have a ten dollar season coming
remember cog this is Teddy it is this is
a ten no it was like now the eros the
Europa I feel like that stuff is all a
fall expansion I feel like that's bigger
you see oh that was cool I'm just saying
what you're talking about is the fall
that is the wind gambit is supposed to
change the Drifters go to another planet
that makes sense
we have Eris morn the shadow keep
expansion is done she's going to figure
out what the hell is out there
she's got we've got potentially other
characters maybe coming into it all of
that fall expansion stuff it you dream
as big as you want cuz them for year
four can go Big Mike curiosities and I
want everybody in chat too seriously
everybody shouts like dammit let the
dream live yeah might shut down sorry I
just shut that one down we don't know
what it is Layton
do you think my big question has always
been like the only tied to any weird
lore bits we've had Rasputin and Siva
it's the only thing in my head that
seems like there it would give any
connection to connection to the next
Rises late unless there's like some
weird thing on the almighty that we let
loose but I don't picture what that
would be I could tell you who I want to
show up but I know probably and that
gonna happen
ooh we just got a major bombshell about
a certain supercomputer not only killing
hell fell winter yeah right we got fell
with but we got a I in law we do for
some iron Lords we do for some salad and
wretched like what is Saladin feel about
all this right this Siva was created it
was fraudulent like it was it was
straight-up it was something that this
robot because his jealous that his
little son is out here him fraternizing
with humans and he feel away you know
his little spy and do what it was
supposed to do and learn from his
transgressions he feels he feels sorry
now although I feel sorry now yes but I
mean I would like some like Saladin has
been ever since rise of iron he has just
been relic
to showing up you know I'm saying like
it's like you know a pop they come visit
you you know to see his kid every two
three weeks and Diddy out you know say
he got visitation rights when I bet he
leave like we need some solid in man
like saladin me come on Jess don't be
like that
sounding need some love fam sadly some
lovey yo
those are his I wait lives like murder
the only thing is we literally did these
salad and ironed there was an expansion
based on him look how long that was
though I know that but I'm just saying
like how would they do want to they want
to tell different stories I don't think
they want to go down not like the whole
DLC gotta be about him but can we get a
moment where he be pop in yo say like
like kill can we get a pull up moment
like fair like can you roll up like we
need these answers man hi like we just
gotta have this secret that like I don't
know man
it's just I always curious to see how
they retired to your room for now if you
tell to get over the looks creepers out
of control sadly these dances that's all
I'm saying it needs to be a reckoning
for salad man it's like so extra said
this may be mean but what if the whole
community had to choose between reviving
cave for good or a darkness subclass and
honestly it's honestly the only reason
is I don't want Kade to come back ever
mostly because it takes away from the
way back to my moment cuz there's like
all you can you know you can undo edit
undo on anything and that's just like
his death meant something and it needs
to get that way and it needs to stay
that way and Nathan Fillion is quite
he's employed doing quite well not doing
voiceover work anymore so he's good oh
yeah yeah I just don't see any got no
ghosts at that's the other day like
could we stop with the cave y'all like
this man's ghost is gone no ghosts no
revive I get it I miss them too but we
need to we need to keep that weight will
you keep that weight man and it was
Aldrin that takes away the object
Redemption man I know y'all don't like
him with I'm just saying it's a cool
storm at some point yeah it's like at
some point yeah he's got to get the
redemption story gotta get the
redemption man I gotta get there now
that's another person who I would like
but I don't know if they they I'm so
almost given up on Aldrin they go and do
this
to be honest I don't even see where it
fits now because if we doing a destiny
Avengers endgame you know are we ever
gonna touch the Dreaming city ever of
the way you know how no dad I miss the
other speculation was Earth's curse of
Osiris season of dawn war mind season of
worthy Morse akin right season of
redacted like the timing of those timing
is dreamy city but it's like and that's
why I was lace it would be interesting
to like walk in this hour and again I
think somebody said it at one point
we're in the tower watching the almighty
and it's like can you see him take off
his hat his helmet and older and stand
in there in the tower you see I Cora
freak the hell out and Layton and then
that's the point where like maybe it's
an older and story and Mara is like one
of the main pieces that like that's her
reason to come back for the fall
expansion I've heard that being rather
theories like well they're go scroll
again he say Amara is Sabbath on that's
his wild day I don't know about this one
they see he's been running with this
Mara it I mean I'm sure stranger things
have happened
but mmm it also seems like I don't think
she would I'm
she's a trickster so of course it could
be some grand crazy as planned but hmm I
don't think she would she and her three
techy and witches would do what they did
to try and stop Boris if she was sabbath
hoon unless it's like a much longer play
than I would ever have imagined and even
right that would probably be a stretch
even for some bungee lore writers out
there just like this Sam the whoa can
kill it again for Trish we be suppose
you'd be I definitely would like in this
season this is a weird time E because we
literally have no connective thread to
what the hell the next season's gonna be
you're still promoting September and
they're not promoting this thing and I'm
like this is weird
we're about to start a season and don't
even know the name we're about like this
is we oh yeah it's very very very
bizarre
so mmm-hmm interesting well there was at
Wahb yes albeit not giant ly surprising
there were a couple of nice things in
there mm-hmm
so tartlet started bungee as we started
out the podcast they you know as for the
events unfolding this week they had
their tweet out there they had all the
links for all the places where you guys
if you need to look up information they
have a lot of links out there talking
about black lives matter so make sure
you guys check out their tweet I know
they're working on donating any of their
employees that donate their matching
they're supporting all of those and
everything and then I mean and this is
one where I don't want to take away but
literally Pride Month is starting in
June as well like based on the nation of
is it a new one I have the first one all
because I think they added um obviously
as yet we have our lgbtqia+ youth but I
believe they said yeah they're the new
in the committee I wait till he gets
back and I'll read it but um yeah they
definitely added here we go he's back
here so he says on the Diversity
Committee said that property was
specifically designed it does but you
just always have the brown black and
brown stripes and I think that's go
yeah it's like a picture so you guys can
say if it'll show focused and we go
right so uh yeah that's that's the
original one yep right now I'm gonna I'm
ordering this one too because this one
has the black and brown stripes again
completely inclusion don't don't gesture
you know I'm saying to support a
positive thing
so it means salute you know I'm saying
overlay oh oh so yeah funnel list there
yeah give them get on the list
well actually was it was a it's
unavailable already let sold out yeah oh
I'm lucky then I wasn't even who I was
able to purchase are you okay yeah I was
able to purchase with it went up so I'm
good you know me so yeah this is really
cool I'm saying accent for all you know
class matter LGBTQIA community just
social support so we they doing that
I think they receive a cold for the true
colors emblem you know I'm saying what's
a show below so those are the initial
two initiatives and then we got that uh
a real thing yeah so if you go to desk
bungie.net slash reveal all it shows us
tune in for the next chapter of destiny
to June ninth 2029 a.m. Pacific now when
is 9:00 a.m. Pacific
that is literally when the servers go
down and season of the worthy ends at
least I'm kind of right on that season
shuts down they turn off the stream I
did soul had you did call and I was like
asking for too much but yeah you there
go there apparently trying to time it
from oh they're gonna be couple faces
sitting in front of kitchens and things
like that and doing some live streams
they're gonna be putting up some viaduct
trailers and things it's and then they
and again this they they show the little
drifter teaser coordinates receive the
future of Destiny to arrives something
calls it's time to answer an heiress
comes in mm-hmm well that's it that's
all this in the name of the chat they
haven't and they said the next chapter
they said they're gonna reveal the next
season and the next chapter so I mean
this viaduct is gonna talk about how
we're going into season 11 and in year
four this is their e3 year for September
fall DLC expansion talk at the same time
this is all going down mm-hmm am I gonna
stream I will 100% be streaming on
Tuesday I will be stream I am off work I
work Monday morning on
gonna sleep in and I'm gonna stream and
probably play all that damn day so I
will be awake for it whatever goes down
definitely come hang out in this chat oh
we have to see what what I'm doing that
day so it was a yeah to ease up to I
will be here so you will know where to
find it then I will be right here in
this chair with little my buddy else's
wish we'll see let's see I've knowing
that if he got shot to pull me in this
home I'm no addict yeah let's see yeah
yeah design yeah so we have a preview
for two point nine point oh so the patch
coming with season of the redacted we
have a patch and we still don't know the
name of the past season that goes with
the maps like is this so stupid
yeah I've been so bad I missed you so
you want to educate me yeah so a lot of
this stuff they have mentioned there's a
couple kind of cool nuggets but a lot of
this is stuff they've kind of mentioned
or balancing things some are actually
quite really good actually
hold on clear the throat they did throw
clean throat and so ever verse few jobs
back we talked about the future of ever
verse and how we're making changes to
some other wards structured to better
balance game player awards and ever
verse content season with redacted will
contain a few introductory changes with
more ships coming in season 12 so this
is a start this they've already sounds
pretty good 12 is gonna be bigger so mmm
legendary arm ornaments
as noted in previous 12 we have shifted
the seasonal of an armored offering to a
game player award for aspirational
content cool there's actually a way to
go earn cool-looking stuff in the game I
think everybody's on board season pass
added an additional 2300 bright dust to
the season pass I'll take it literally
any bright dust in that season pass you
can do it there's no me to dust
you know brighten doesn't purchases
added a flare section to the features to
feature shaders and spawn effects it's
fine they're just moving categories
around mm-hmm highly requested items
from previous seasons will once again be
available we're looking you wishes of
sorrow and I want you to look up what
that is which is a sorrow soon oh it's
the ornament for thorn oh okay gotcha
got you got you got you gift I saw
somebody tweet about that this morning
so yeah yeah yeah mm-hmm we will once
again communicate season 11 silver only
items at the beginning of a season we're
expecting to have an update later in
season 11 on further changes to
brightness acquisition so keep your eyes
peeled good mm-hmm
and again that's one of those things
like even something like overwatch yeah
they have boxes but you are kind of
continually earning that currency slowly
just by playing the game now they don't
have bounties and we have to get
bounties for it but still just like just
a little like every soft you knew a
crystal match oh cool I got a hundred
brightness like every soft to just throw
it at the people for playing your game
all they got to do so low forgiving Lola
absolutely sandbox powerful friends mod
now if you guys haven't seen this thing
this is the season of the season of dawn
mod that is the charge of the Light type
stuff but the bonus that comes with it
is a plus 22 mobility mmm hunters love
this thing because then they get their
their stats stacked up they live on
mobility the powerful friends mod will
no longer stack and there's a reason
they say that if multiple copies of this
mater equipped the mods will know will
provide no bonus that's understands only
only solar seasonal mods are intended to
stack no part of art mods hat are
intended to have stacking functionality
powerful friends granted +22 mobility
which players could leverage to get
three stat columns to met the max 100
points the commune the mod is not price
of
to justify its benefits and increasing
its cost with an adverse effects on the
primary benefit usage season Lebanon
introduces a new arc mod so we know we
got new mods coming you know granting a
similar stat bonus to strength and will
not stack so right
basically powerful friends and even I've
heard low no say this is like powerful
friends is like a hunter's like that
mods on a hunter if they're playing in
PvP they want the +22 mobility you have
no other way to get that you're gonna
use that thing again they need to find
ways to tone things and make new cool
mod so cool stuff enhance Auto rifle
odor fusion rifle Oh turbo loader armor
mods now have a chance to drop from
pinnacle sources like that's good like
Jim pinnacles hey I did my pinnacle oh
cool I got a mod like not just Ironman
not just I am banished trying to force
us in there yeah that's a good thing
raid rewards this Brotherhood the
biggest one it's not popular on Twitter
raid rewards the following raid exotics
have in now increased drop chances
finally right how old is all this crap
that was from first se caen so that was
the start of year two and we're going
into year four so it's two year old
grade panarchy which was literally three
months later and always on time the
exotic Sparrow from the secret chest and
scourge of the past drop chances begin
at 10 percent and increased to a max of
50 percent over 20 clears and 20 clears
is a lot 20 quiz a lot fan you new 20
raids that's a lot so that thought it'd
be a little nicer but hey no I want you
to read the next one cuz this is your
all-new I have not really had a chance
things been so crazy I'm not gonna
transfer this is no Charles Awards
additional masterwork material rewards
now drop at three five and seven trials
wins okay added a trials weekly bounty
which unlocks trials in grams on c14 the
bounty reward will match the win
three-mile storm award of the week okay
trials tokens distribution has been
rebalanced to focus on wins three five
and seven of a trials passage this
includes repeat passages trials tokens
are no longer awarded from match
completion soreness big tokens are now
granted specifically through wins and
bounties passage of wealth now doubles
the bonus trials tokens earned at three
five and seven trials wins hope you
enjoy this appetizer full course and
more coming on unite see you then
this is interesting yeah this is
interesting
yeah new to me so the first thing is the
master work materials right long overdue
it's the few only um pinnacle activity
that's not doing what the nightfall is
doing and giving you you know at least a
chance at some activities now it looks
like they changed the focus on the winds
as far as to token so tokens are no
longer that's what I'm stuck on right
now tokens are no longer awarded from
match completions they only granted
specifically through wins and bounties
so you get a win did you get tokens you
complete bounties
and then you get tokens so they've just
taken it away from so basically if you
lose you ain't getting it and now you
think that's discouraging though there's
people doing about that yeah there's
people who want to try try yeah like if
I go in and I get like I mean Paul
tetsuo says like he and a couple friends
they try and try and try and they cannot
get that three wins to save their lives
like just the three and not saying he's
bad it's just how the player base and
the way it's stacked and how some of
that stuff goes those low-level cards
now the incentivization for like the
five or the seven if you really want
those tokens needs to be huge we've said
that before I don't care if it's fifty
if it's a hundred it like if you get a
to seven wins you work your butt off
especially on the way some of the player
bases now I like to barely reward
matching the three we're miles now
that's what I like if you're not if
you're getting some kills like math
whatever the bounty is that may take
away from the tokens being kind of thing
that's a concession to old trials I just
do the body at least you can get there
for yeah you can get the three wind drop
of the week if you just play enough to
finish the bounty I like that district
okay distribution okay
ATandT that disick lose repeat passes
under there I don't know how I feel
about that token part and then the
passage of wealth without doubles bonus
trials tokens earn three and farmers so
okay that's okay yeah like I said I
don't know I I want to know what the
thought process man I mean oh no solid
asset freeze and a big-ass cross has
something on the line that you've
marginalized casuals a little boy yeah I
believe are interesting to see the final
finished product yeah like again you
take if you take anything away from the
person who gets one or two wins I feel
like that might be a mistake yeah cuz
the person gets one or two wins it's
like hey at least if I get one or two
I'm slowly gonna accumulate some tokens
maybe I do get the third of my I can use
them and I'll work on the bounty but if
I literally like just do the bounty and
I don't see my aunt and my wins have
been like one two losing out one two
losing out their incentive to against
stay in the playlist goes away
that I'm worried about I'm worried that
this this still hasn't addressed the
casual staying involved in engaging I
know I don't see how that necessarily
these all you know somewhere okay but I
still don't feel out that passage part
yes you go now Charles bounty that's the
three win thing okay but that's their
only way to get something if they get to
the three wins if somebody struggles to
get to three ones in the first place the
bounties the only thing they're gonna
get and then if it's just like get a
certain number kills they'll do those do
those and they're like at three and five
set or each man then again like mmm
does it get sweaty or towards the top
how much and again you know it's how
they incentivize the vote route the
seven and the chest row
if 7.2 winds is big enough then maybe it
starts to pull and again although all
with a tweed they need to do they need
to hold the high skill players to the
higher ends of those cards yes that's
the whole goal of what everybody's been
asking for is like if you do the three
wind token farm thing you're pissing
everybody off right again if you can
still farm three tokens and get the
three wind shotgun does that look like
this even changed they may put more at
the end mm-hmm but if I can still go
through do three root three ones get a
shot do it get the shotgun if it's on
that week and then I turn around reset
and I still get my three wins mmm it
still doesn't feel like they're pulling
them high enough the way the rotations
and stuff go I don't feel like it's
getting far enough D there's not enough
doesn't I don't read this as enough
incentive at the end of a card to make
people really go for the flaws but some
people just love it have fun and do it
alright but I mean I even saw fallout
yesterday he was working on carries two
three winds to try and get people to
shotgun yeah so even for new people but
again you have somebody like fallout no
offense to him he's damn good player but
it's like doing it they're wrecking that
one two three wind part of the playlist
over and over and over and over because
that's where they can get what they need
as opposed to mm-hmm
I'll say I don't know how to change that
busted three win window right the Bali
you don't have to get the three wins to
get the reward of the three least that's
how I'm reading it yeah no I mean yeah
that's positive that's positive because
it's like okay I don't have to get
through as long as I just get two kills
or do whatever the hell they're telling
me that's fine but you know I do agree
that the incentive to stay in you know
I'm saying I don't know how like we got
to keep the higher point to the high and
keep the casuals in and I don't know if
that's just gonna be enough like is that
you know I don't know man I don't know
and in its a person as far as the adept
yeah that's coming later they gonna do
it but we have no right for it December
13 a December that's the Adept stuff
yeah that's a dead but um yeah we had a
seaman he says more about this as a that
is an appetizer
so you know overly there's more so we
don't know what's going on June 9th
yeah I was like just the way I read this
and again misses and everything but the
way I read this it still doesn't feel
like it shifts the playerbase too far
into the cart enough
all I'm saying so I may not know it all
that's just what I'm reading yeah no no
I frame a feeling now I'm not gonna go
through the entire next section in full
detail yeah but basically what they're
doing is they're letting you choose
custom button mapping for your
controller for accessibility for moving
things around they had some cool stuff
of like you know how on hard let you
have to hold and reload you might be
able to set that up for a double tap you
can change some of the functionality of
things but and that's the way they say
is like you know throw and that they
even describe they have like different
verbs they use for like throw activate
and all those things and it's like it's
a weird way for them to try and define
their controller scheme mm-hmm but
overall like the accessibility is huge
for everybody mm-hm
choosing how you want to play with your
controller maybe you want this button
here you just don't like the way it
feels
you can remap quite a bit instead of
just having default 1 2 3 or 4 you can
be as goofy as you want to be you can
change up all that stuff but one of the
big ones and what was it lucky you
tweeted it and I tweeted its you mm-hmm
you want to say it because I'm been
talking about somebody mentioned on
Twitter and I think it was lucky but
probably where I saw it first but you
have controller remapping for people
between PC and consoles and other things
and other places for accessibility for
everyone and honestly the question was
is this leading to cross play yeah I
think I think you would have to I think
that's still listen we've been on the
record for wanting to do cross play
right this was during the PlayStation
exclusive kind of days so to me when I
see stuff like this is like because the
question is like now right why now why
we why is this let's be real like the
community this wasn't high on the
community's list of things you need to
be doing right now opposed to this right
we
like it right but I don't feel like this
was on the top of the bucket list of the
communities most wanted things Bungie
needs to handle now damn it like that
wasn't on the top so this to me is
something that I see is what I consider
bulletin board stuff that they have been
planning and wanting to do for the
evolution of the game and when I see
this I it screams to me bigger picture
eventually making the transition to
cross play easier and I'm saying and
generally every season whether it be
September every big expansion they have
made some type of substantial um you
know what you call it jump or shot the
Ares Karthi would go for that flawlessly
yes brother yes yes I would like to go
for that flawless this weekend yes thank
you salute to Ares in a team Oh many
y'all got me my helmet got me much yeah
I'm feeling like a pharaoh again like I
am a happy man salute to Ares in the
team and riot squad I know them boys but
um yeah back on point I I think this is
a prelude to club now here's the thing
now we have to be clear
PvE yes if it is a cross play set up PvP
either no or optional yeah I was like
the optional like I mean what holiday D
does and you can opt in to play with
whoever you want maybe you got friends
in different places and you just know
it's not always gonna be the same and
again mm-hmm I may suck on PC and
somebody with a controller on console
still could probably shoot me right but
yeah like I I agree you want the option
to give people on console be like I want
to play against mouse and keyboard and
all those crazy people and they can
choose but also making that choice like
you may limit your player base or
whatever but at least if it's console
yeah you lose the state Alyssa van I
don't know it's they I think but I'm not
also that loss which stadia if they do
it because stadia has shown with shot
them I think pop G's their first one day
they're doing cross play with PC on
stadia Oh
gee now again that's these a whole
different beast I don't know how that
will work
I don't know where that lambs would stay
do that that is a very interesting thing
if cross plays to happen and does W have
dedicated servers I don't know if that
would be the question is if you're doing
any bit of peer-to-peer stadia being set
up on its own dedicated servers versus
peer-to-peer matchmaking and connections
over here yeah the speed of talking
between those three crazy different
environments between PC on Steam and
having some of its cheating issues
console having some connection and still
using the peer-to-peer networking the
way they do that and then mmm
stadia being like the most dedicated but
you got a little bit of like everybody's
on the same page but you got a tiny bit
of lag like those yeah those are not the
same environment and if you cross play I
feel like there's just like lots of red
question marks that come and be like
who's who's just mess it up this lady's
I really think with cross play show just
face your team but face out of here but
listen the option is cool though I think
if someone wants to jump in the mix you
know I'm saying and they don't care and
there should be an option it should be
it probably should be default off and
then it actually opt-in because I will
say this though this does wonders for
lobbies and online just player base
searching for a match I'll tell you who
want it if static is about the way
dammit they need bigger or like you go
search for a batch in stadia whoa
tumbleweeds don't man you know say but
yeah I think I think I hope it would be
beneficial I just think about doing
strikes and you know stickball guided
games something that's really been in
the bushes right guys gains have been
like think about all these other things
that can really use a little boost in in
playlist so um yeah like III want it I
just want it optional for PvP PvE it's a
no-brainer
like right like we don't gotta promise
eat right you all the way live right
everyone why not he yeah that would be
I'll be kind of that would be kind of
cool yeah to me that's what sets it up
now let me ask you this though arm
do you think someone asked me there's I
want to ask you about if cross-play is
coming do you think console should add
optional mouse and keyboard support
and if you can somehow set it up why
would I mean yes that a trick question
what am I meant what am I missing there
about either I mean Keith Wiggin it's a
it's a peripheral whether you hold it in
your hands you got your hand on a
keyboard mouse if it's how you want to
play the game my brother would love that
if he was playing a console game in like
it like controller maybe one of those
things like holding it for a long time
doesn't feel great in your hands or
whatever but now if there's just
literally a nexus s Emma words there's
an accessibility preference for somebody
on any platform I don't see why not
especially with the new consoles coming
not that far away well six months but
still when those things drop in the foot
like what their PCs you should be able
to plug a keyboard and a mouse in so if
I pull out my playstation over here I'm
just like mm-hmm but question now what
about half we say yes is it an unfair
advantage for console guys going against
other console guys who don't have mouse
and keyboard should they be in their own
Lobby should they be in the PC lobby
I mean if you take you Tedy Bruschi
mm-hmm I don't know cool guys I think he
was working on it he's more of a
controller guy I know was working on
mouse and keyboard hmm I know controller
feels like it's got its aim assist
I know mouse and keyboard has some more
stability on certain guns that people
like him laser beams on mm-hmm I'm not
to the level where I'm gonna care I mean
that's me like I'm not at the point to
be like hey somebody has that aim-assist
advantage they can shoot me like by 0.5
microseconds better because they can
control their mouse here versus people
are insanely skilled with a controller
it is impressive and the dexterity my
thumbs I'm just out of practice on that
stuff and I like the way mouse and
keyboard feels that it's balanced that
way does there need to be like the
fortnight balancing mm per control or
aim assist to be less like does that
ever need to be a question because you
plug in a keyboard or you can plug in a
controller it's like the magnetic head
shooting yeah I don't know I mean this
is real but is it an unfair advantage
though it should [ __ ] the minute you
plug it in you automatically into PC
lobby of cross-play I mean it depends on
if the game has it not every game is
gonna have cross play but it's like just
a house that's what I mean
you
want to spy Gani hey I mean if if it
comes with cross play isn't it gonna be
available for everybody everywhere then
you can opt in or you can opt in on who
you play with with what peripherals I
can't do it right now on PC I can play
with people are like well hey let me
plug in my controller and I can go you
know a mrs. Tam on PC and I'm using a
keyboard mouse and some people say
keyboard mouse is easier or like more
accurate to a point but the aim-assist
on controller some people like like yeah
I'm just gonna like magnet to your head
and that's on this platform so what
makes it say that if you plug it on the
on the other side
honestly if somebody's able to like have
a PlayStation set up in TV and a mouse
and keyboard and they can make their
setup work on a couch or the console go
for it because that's gonna work anyway
like I don't know like I don't know if
like Keira knows okay I don't know if I
care enough to care yeah if you have the
option maybe of like but if you start
saying I want to play with this person
here and only mouse and keyboard on this
console but maybe PC players maybe need
like you start fragmenting all these
little playlists what idea is bringing
everybody together so then so then if
that's the case then we eliminating
mouse keyboard on console keep them in
their dedicated space of controller do
you've done the option to opt in if and
how can you limit that though if you go
next-gen and they can true if they're
like pcs and you just plug them in right
but there does did does come the debate
of unfair advantage that the question is
you know a lot of people feel that mouse
and keyboard is superior and they have
an advantage in competitive pvp so they
could say hey i understand what you're
saying as far as how confusing it gets
the minute you plug it in me now you're
in this fragment till i get you yeah
like how many different like they're
trying to make matchmaking times short
for the best like matchmaking they can
have despite where and how you play the
bigger the player base the better the
matchmaking if you start fragmenting all
of these things i get my ass kicked by
somebody sorry language i get my butt
kicked quite some but see people in
games i'll you know play with ares for
five minutes i'm like yeah this is why
I'm not in your skill hello
because I'm getting worked over here
hovering towards the bottom I'll play on
my own or I'll play with my brother he
doesn't play that much so his just
whatnot whatever numbers for his match I
mean just aren't that high I'll go in
there and I'll stop like to me it's not
yeah that's like some games I win some
games I lose and I guess I don't take it
too seriously enough to feel like the
drawbacks of different input controls
somebody can beat me with mouse and
keyboard somebody can beat me with a
controller either way I do it so I don't
think like splitting everybody is worth
like you win some you lose some
to me and that's just me because I'm not
on the level of like now if you're
talking Abe
tournament or something maybe you limit
it there and you literally say hey these
only on puts you can use but just the
general play I don't I don't know I just
I feel like the efforts of bringing
people together would just be taken away
by limiting all these different like
input playlist control matching setups
that's okay I feel I think my gut tells
me they probably won't do it on console
all my far as giving them mouse and
keyboard support that's what my gut
tells me but if they did yeah I kind of
still finish cuz the whole point of we
even talking about lobbies for console
guys cuz we feel peace you guys have the
advantage so you don't look am i against
it no i'm not against it if they offer
it and it happens great we'll get to
that mountain we'll cross you don't
cross it over to get to it um I just
want this thing to happen I just like UI
changes I like that they are making
things more accessible you know
ultimately I agree with you I think that
don't listen the best part about cross
play is on line lobbies there's nothing
more saturd in a game that you like and
the community is not there and it's not
enough people playing you know I'm
saying
again shadow just area I feel God for
guys that only have that game on that's
the on stadia you know what I'm talking
about
except for trials in the weekend shout
the Aries you know saying Charlie the
Wiggins is fine wait times are up for a
very manageable very cool nothing not
abnormal but if you try to do a basic
control match a basic competitive man
you I've seen it 60% of the time time
out and say hey there's not enough
people to look for I'm sorry go play
something else or else yeah stating a
PvP thank you from like people go to
trials for a reason there but you're
just saying the generic PvP is or ghosts
out ya know people are on two trials
clean environment on stadia so the wet
time there's no it's like you in there
like we actually a surprise if you wait
a little bit by the trials what stadia
is moving because that's the popular MO
and a lot of them a lot of the hardcore
EPA's are not coming over there for a
clean environment but if you I've seen
it for you just like during the week
when there's no trials and you're just
trying to play a standard you just want
to do your your your powerful rewards
for the week yeah right you let me just
get in a couple of match bra it is
brutal brutal you can sit in there for
more than thirty minute twenty minutes
the game what I've never seen this game
times our destiny tells you hey man
couldn't find you nothing go do
something else so they know that that's
that platform definitely needs it in
some form but in general it will be cool
for play state think about this
PlayStation four users you know say Xbox
one user like how cool would that be n
let's be real there's a little even my
claim like I lost podcast playing like
we're segmented we are segmented man
it's it's really it's really been you
know cool debt to have you know to see
all your clan members in the same thing
shot the areas he's like comp has been
hasn't been bad for a while how about a
fire look salute to you man I've tried a
few times man it's it's it's sad it's
just like who this is this even strike
sometimes you know Eva strikes even
match made activities I'm does it take a
little bit but I see something that's
not you know kind of on the older side
so that's my feeling but I do think this
is the ultimate set up and it could be a
nice add-on to September you know new
content yeah don't like bigger pillars
there's like the new light cross save
new content there was like three or four
big pillars they want to do you know the
MMO action RPG is like kind of a the
foundation like what if one of the
pillars is cross play that's a huge
advertising point for their fall
expansion of which that's their you know
one of the biggest sources of income so
big-time big-time so what do you think
last question do you think new light
continues
big of DAB there we go there we go bank
of day do I think new light continues
like Oh free
yeah I think they may need to it needs
some love from what I've heard it's
atrocious shy not the tank Teddy put us
on yeah Teddy said it was terrible I've
heard from a couple other people they're
just like wandering blindly through
1,000 quest icons or something it's not
a lot of guidance on that one so it
could be fixed pretty well you know but
the idea of free people coming in cool
free people in trials I can say stop
that please yes stop the free people in
trials maybe trials year 4 has a new
quest that you actually have to give you
some things yeah and you know there's a
little bit more requirements I'll stop
the cheating on top of you know some
people do too Fincher two-factor
authentication was helping I'll call it
duty I know all those different things
can be like worked on but hmm yeah no I
think the free P 3 thing will stay
because it's a steam game it's
free-to-play it's in a lot of places I
think that's a kind of their bread and
butter is a way to tease people in and
if the content continues to be good they
get more people who will eventually buy
but the experience definitely hopefully
got reviewed in the past year yeah and
maybe I mean again if they do things
like blow up Titan and planets go away
or anything like that
maybe the whole experience needs
adjusted somehow and they'll have to
cross that bridge when they get there
but yeah if you think new light stays
they just hopefully give it a good focus
yeah I want you would you it's gonna be
fun man so you right you ready are you
ready for this craziness next week
Almighty explodes sometime in the next
four days reveal of Avengers endgame in
the fall we don't I don't have a clue
what the connection the see I'm honestly
wondering when we get announced what the
seasons gonna be if it's so obvious of
what the connection to the fall is gonna
be that like we're all like now I say
well you couldn't say anything or if
it's gonna be or if it's gonna take like
a little bit of investigating right or
if it's just like everybody's like I see
where we're going and that's I guess the
question somebody said - do you think
season 11 and again I don't have high
expectations for season 11 they've said
it's like nothing else in destiny before
I know I gave you the $10 season remark
and
pulled every but the whole room down
they said seven seas eleven is nothing
like we've seen in destiny before mm-hmm
that's on the viaduct and about the moon
this upcoming one yeah this is heaven no
they said season 10 is like starting
things to get going in season 11 is like
man nothing ever in destiny before they
said that in the moon viaduct and I can
point you to that I will be I'm tempered
the expectations for season 11 and the
main thing is this is still within the
development cycle of the previous
seasons there's only so much that can
change when it comes to the size and
scale of these things and somebody and
earlier is like is it still gonna be
bounties and public events and stuff
like that I'm like or another sundial
activity and honestly that's what I
expect mm-hmm if it's something bigger
and different I will be happily
surprised but I would keep my
expectations in hopefully not a public
event but at least a sundial type thing
some activities and their way to move in
there a reasonable transition going into
Falls crazytown yes it has to be a great
appetizer right it has to be it has to
set this thing up I would like can we
get a new activity I mean is that asking
I don't know I mean that's like yeah
it's a sundial sundial sundial worthy
not vex offensive definitely not a
public event I mean if you review season
of the worthy you went to the law
sectors you've already been to they just
literally champions in them you know the
bunkers were new but what did those take
literally four minutes three minutes
like you got a roll you clear a couple
champions you're out mm-hmm and then you
had the public event in three places on
three planets of which we've already
done publicans but you do one you do it
like ten and a half million times later
that's that's what the seasons made of
is public events and stuff like that so
we get to see what the weapons set Sun
setting numbers start looking like yes
we get to see the are more Sun setting
numbers we get to see the stuff about
what's gonna be kind of shifting how
long these metas live I can't tell
anybody enough make sure you get
felwinter's lie cuz it's gonna live in
PvP for nine months don't miss that
quest that's part of my to-do list
yesterday mmm
I'm talking to addict now you gotta get
it together
snobby esse to get it done yeah yet if
you ever sure ever track the cannon
oh yeah that's literally all I did sir
cheat tractor can and knock it out
you're going to video mine I like the I
was like oh that's the wave right there
so good listen my brother the night fell
winter came out and we're like it's like
I heard the cast Ellen's pretty girls
like all right and here right he and I
were just like holding down two doors
and you know it was fun when you're
chatting and knocked it out but if you
wanna go knock it out by yourself
especially if you have a warlock do a
devout warlock build with a tractor
cannon land a whole bunch of shotgun
mods yeah no time at all you're not bad
and if you haven't owned fourth Horseman
get to the point in the quest reunion
the shotgun shotgun kills and do them
together together multi-tool has an
efficiency work work smarter not harder
there you go there we go yeah it's gonna
be fun now I can't wait I want to see
okay like you said tempering
expectations because these are they're
worthy mm-hmm oh it's just and it's
still within this cycle and again their
development cycle they were working on
she's another redacted either during
undying or done it's been they haven't
taken the feedback about please get rid
of the batteries in the public events
that ain't there that they haven't ever
enough time to implement that right
right not feel that I'm fit yeah miss
mister Qaddafi give me a reason to keep
coming back that's all of what listen
yeah you know we will have it you know
we'll have a new artifact will have a
new storyline which I'm we that we're
dying to know and um you know we just
need like I said we need content respect
respect of time investment don't you
know we got it we got to see I was
definitely looking forward to it to a
new meta I would love a new sandbox
which we should happen you know they
said it was an appetizer today you know
so I mean yesterday so we should get
some nice changes there see what goes on
and see what they had
I'm dying to know what the adder
artifact brings as far as the weapons
they're going to push us towards I'm
very curious about that as I'm cuz we
had I think we have pulses in the first
season and I haven't had them since and
I'm like my knees in a pulse one more
time before they're really overtired
mm-hmm
that is one thing late as we go into
next season it'll be kind of the way to
look into year four but it's like also I
know these seasons have been set up this
way I want them to evolve the artifact
in the fall mmm
because language paalam one champion
mods column to reload perks column three
glimmer stuff column four five stuff I
like kind of tie into some of the
seasonal stuff and whatever but it was
like
I've seen that same setup for a year and
while it's you know it's it's a way to
mix some things up I just I want and I
don't want to see an evolution of it
over the expansion I want to just I want
to see an evolution I don't know exactly
what I want I would like to see you know
somebody just say like hey you can earn
your champion MA you can earn in a stop
abroad and it just goes in a primary mmm
you're gonna earn the end they can go in
weapons and maybe you have to go out and
fight for them maybe somewhere and earn
those but like the whole hey you're
gonna fight champions with sidearms
and submachine guns and I'm like I have
to go give a giant unstoppable ocher a
hug just to shut him down and like
that's terrifying yes like some of it is
like as with the weapons sunsetting and
stuff like that depending on what
archetypes are active or not in tough
activities the more they keep shrinking
down you're gonna be it feels like if
they don't give some flexibility you're
gonna be like they're like hey when you
start a season bungees basically going
to tell you so when you run night falls
you're gonna be running hand cannons for
your unstoppable mods you're gonna be
running this pulse rifle for your
barrier buds and and it's like they're
gonna make it so cookie cutter they take
away almost the reason for some of the
loot so they need to give some
flexibility both with the mods and the
champions you have all that stuff a
little bit that's a that's a ball
evolution I'm crossing my fingers for
I'm with said freed I am so sick of
community events I am so sick of do
three weeks of this to build this thing
together and let's do it guys right the
livestock farming brah I am so sick
sixty-five million public events guys
keep it going yeah no no we're not there
that's not it
no more fake of community events
please Bungie I'm just I know we're
gonna get one oh you know alright cuz
they got it they got X trucks this thing
out all right know what they gonna do
so that's like temper that stuff till
September yeah we stretching right now
I've got do I'm telling y'all right now
I'm gonna be the bad bah-humbug
community member when it comes to those
I am not participating I am yes I am The
Grinch
I am the Grouch I am that guy of
Christmas bah humbug no community event
see you next season when it's over after
the week and I'll clean the rewards off
don't your hard work I'm telling you now
I'm not doing it
please don't get a beat don't put it in
a quest step that involves something and
some cool exotic oh no no no no no so
cuz we kind of a young shadows over
there like we just gotta do something I
would like some cool I would like some
cool story beats to continue you know
whether it be lore I own that I like
guest Slayer I understood your community
events I am bah humbug and your numbers
and your stocks and your fractal line
and all that well it's not best to get
your compounding interest over weeks 1 2
& 3 your payoff in week 4 is gonna be
much bigger if you hold off and do your
investments ability I'm looking at a
stock ticker what the hell like I wanted
the fun in theory boat that's just walk
around give it a bro they got to make me
- bah humbug community event um oh it's
just like it's a blurred hand yeah it's
the blur the blur steam oh yeah mmm yeah
man that's when I got lazy yeah we got
like next week's podcast is gonna be so
much to talk about
cuz this season we don't know there's
not like hey we got a trailer we got a
[ __ ] nothing nothing we thought for two
hours and you guys stuck with us so
thank you first off thank you
hey yeah next week long-long point I'm
sure and we have eight guests coming
I've sent you guys to him some of my
streams to him before but if you guys
have seen a maze Cognito is gonna work
on the intro and that man may turn
around and drop some bars
awesome awesome guys so none he's not
live right now otherwise that Sindhu you
guys over to him but mm-hm
yeah guess next week and it's gonna be
an evening show as well if you guys are
listening and you want to catch it live
you'll be an evening show so think 6-7
p.m. Eastern something like that it will
be evening for sure so just a switch in
time if you guys are listening this one
you know what's coming next week yes sir
yes sir but I don't
at this point I'm basically just gonna
be watching Twitter I'm gonna stare Sun
for the next two hours in-game if I see
the Sun doesn't change today I'm gonna
go make a serve video I finished
spider-man last night by the way you
guys have a ps4 please play spider-man
yes Oleg
it was conducting heartstrings last
night man yeah yeah dude good game good
game good game
one of the best superhero character
games - yeah it's really good game
somebody on my stream last night was
saying like they liked the spectacular
spider-man story for comics like the
best portrayal of spider-man and the
game and I was like it was good it was
very good yeah I finished it said read
last night yes I was at like 67 68 % of
the campaign and then it wouldn't so
kinda go do the next story mission all
of a sudden it was like
a couple things together and then it was
like we're like going cinematics and
rolling credits I was like oh damn like
it came faster than I thought it would
so all year there's a joke in that sense
by the way that we've been over you
don't buy anything you guys don't know
we might live my mind lives half in the
gutter and just range open at bay most
decided Phil arias it's a little airs a
little bit all the time though though
yeah it's like I mean for me I I made it
through a couple games played inside a
beat neo2 nice except New Game+ is like
a whole different game of neo2 so
there's so much more there I'm probably
not gonna go full trophy list on
spider-man but you know this weekend I
might stock up some bounties it's pretty
much all I got left
yeah I might have to get down to have it
how's my Titans done right so it would
be warlock kind of hunter so it's only
two and then the big thing is for
anybody who listens to this especially
today or tomorrow mmm today being Friday
Saturday Sunday and Monday if you don't
have fourth Horseman you have one set of
rotations of the quarry going through
that loss sector left one time was
actually unless it's two unless it's
today's then you might have to was you
potentially have one more time that you
see the lost sector that you can finish
that quest yeah so don't forget it
but yeah I think I'm probably just gonna
like maybe play maybe do you know one
more pit of heresy if I guess mmm like I
will say Ares and I ran one of his
friends through it yeah might have been
done in 30 minutes
we blew through a bit of heresy now like
do that you can rules like it was
especially once I take the time to
practice like soloing one mm I know
everything to do so now I'm like I'll
just play carelessly and I'll die more
but so much faster like with both some
people in there oh my god it's all yeah
battle take everything you got a guy's
gotta take care of now you got that
video coming right remaining bucket list
items er oh it's up okay yeah sure the
one yeah yesterday so I basically put up
a big to-do list and it's covering like
all the stuff that's going away
basically everything related to the
season is going the public events where
you can farm the Sarah the war mine pods
the bunkers are going away where you buy
some of the other mods
and also spend your currencies if you
have more line bits left over you can
spin the currencies on those chipsets
and get like basically token packages
from the bunker that's how you can get
some more rolls on these weapons the
weapons are still gonna last for nine
months and the mods are gonna be on your
character forever if you have them all
so you can toy your handles warmind sell
builds for another nine months if you
have the weapon so don't forget about
those those are actually fairly cool if
you dive into a big build and they're
kind of one of the biggest underrated
things they're so underrated in the
season very nice bill with that
absolutely
like the felwinter's lie lore which is
just a crying shame that that quest is
leaving the game that's the FOMO stuff
that like I'll be happy then they stop
doing yes like having that being able to
go save saint-14 be able to going to the
moon bunker like that stuff needs to
hang around of the game for a while and
next year we'll but the lore for fell
winter and Rasputin's is legit OC that
stuff it's a sex max really good stuff
your season pass pull everything out of
there yeah and also your previous season
pass if there's anything you forgot from
season of dawn you can go into
bungie.net click on season progress and
it'll show you anything you didn't pick
up from your previous season pass send
it straight into your character they'll
only do one previous season so he's gone
but like I missed some glimmer in like
one exotic Engram glimmer glimmer like I
clicked on it on the website about half
a second later in game and game like
it's fast and then exotic and rip like
go go check all the place so bungie.net
check your season progress of previous
season pull your stuff out you got your
triumphs if there's anything else like I
need to go or a full set of serifs a
seven sarah farmer and clean out a monk
or i literally just forgot i don't care
too much about Transpo time like this is
some pretty easy once i can probably
already yeah he's got to clean it out
okay mmm spend your currencies like the
bounties for the weapons you've got the
encrypted warm line bits it's two of
those per bounty and then you have your
daily weapon purchase which is only like
sixty so you got to spend the chipsets
you can blow through most of those today
if you want to rob i don't think of
anything else and then yeah if you want
to prepare
bounties weekly is the priority then
dailies and then repeatable x' if you
need to fill any holes depending on
how much time you put into it but like
it's your core activities don't save up
like seven Sara flake don't save up
bunker bunnies they're probably gone
little a gambit from gambit strikes
crucible gunsmith and both eros and the
lectern those should all carry over in
between those six things you're gonna
have a fair amount of activities so
absolutely mm-hmm yeah there's like 16
or 18 mods total so try and get them all
yeah yeah that's all I got least stacked
and ready to go and if you're ready are
you doing your bow anything I got to
start getting going on that just get a
little bit of a jump as I've been
slacking but I'll try to I'll try to do
those handles ready to be cashed out on
reset provided Bungie doesn't do
anything crazy and say hey those that's
a giant disclaimer they could always be
like hey bounty clean-out like they
could do it but it would at least be
known that I've done it on one character
and probably playing at least one more
so I'm gonna put some time in betting
that it's there because they haven't
said it yet mm-hmm I'm just that
mmmh cat that's all I got what do you
got coming up anything weekend
podcasting to get stuff for you know
long kind you know Twitter all yeah I
law now I want to jinx it but
potentially could be a big Sunday ILP so
um yeah it could be you know I've been
talking to - if people follow me on
Twitter there's been a philosophical
debate but that happened to jump on my
timeline between it started with me
basically the question was you know
whose philosophy as far as next
generation do I kind of subscribe to and
normally I don't usually give my
thoughts on Twitter like that cuz part
of me is like you know I like to really
like your mind but which like I can tell
you my theory on that okay okay
me now okay you just say to general oh
no like for like the whole neck you're
saying like the ps5 the next gen versus
the like Gen X Box that's the big versus
you know start off on the on the new
joint yes honestly there's upsides to
both but for me my preference its
playstation right so um and there's been
a lot that I could order sentiment so
basically how this whole thing started
was people all shout out set free Wow
thank you brother he said finally got a
chance to check out I love podcast the
geology hopefully I tune in tonight
thank you but much appreciate um yeah so
basically I start out someone asked me
this that you know I respect I gave an
answer and I just said look I'm torn
because I'm like you II when new tech
comes out
I like the latest the greatest I want to
see the tech pushed I'm a techie I want
to see the next generation the evolution
of what technically couldn't be done
before right
but I did say you know to the opposite
side where the Xbox is for delivery I
said it is super pearl consumer that I
can keep my you know current gen titles
or whatever and then let's say for
example cyberpunk right no sorry Punk is
gonna have some more deliveries so if I
buy cyberpunk for the Xbox one
X when the series X comes out I'm gonna
have all these in the hands but I don't
have to buy the game again you know that
kind of stuff so that whole forward
backward compatibility and then
and you know in hand stuff so I
understand both you know kind of thing
so I just left it I went to sleep I
didn't think anything else so next thing
I seen was you know two executives that
I really respect you know I'm saying and
kind of jumped on my timeline and was
like hey you're a cog you're kind of
wrong because you know um oh basically
they was saying that the old hardware
does it the way game design works it was
explained like it doesn't hold it back
it's kind of like what Microsoft's doing
there's a PC kind of a thing where you
know the the 10 60 the the 28 is not
held by about a 10 60 kind of thing so
I'm like okay this person's in the
industry I trust your judgment you've
been around game development thank you
for input II I'm thinking it's done
right ready to go Bell's like I'm sorry
but I can honestly like say that's not
100% right but anyway um well this
person went into a six tweet thread I
believe it who was part of games but
literally gave me why yeah continue no
he just said to me that was a false
choice that I presented and that game
design no longer works like that and
that he said there are some exceptions
but is the gist of what he said was that
you know did the idea of things being
held act back because of the older thing
is not true which was surprised because
I thought it was the case yeah like I
will show you the tweets so that was
that was one exactly then another exec
jumped in and say yeah I hear what
you're saying on a tough choice but you
know I want the latest and greatest in
technology to be push so I said we'll
look I respect both you guys how about
you come what I hope you to talk about
so they are both you know in the
industry I don't want to spoil I don't
want to jinx it because they have very
prominent people um hopefully you know
we will get this tap in this Sunday if
not you know I'm not really work on it
yeah yeah you know so it's in the works
hopefully it happens this Sunday would
be great so it's kind of like a mini
pseudo debate between the executive
thick yeah so we'll see if it happens
and yeah man that that's kind of like to
the plan obviously are loads of gaming
down there please check that out for us
a lot of tremendous
- Josh Brener shout to the whole team
and cut out a tremendous statement you
know in reference to what's going on
kind of similar to what we did today and
just you know providing information
things if you don't know what to do if
you don't know how to help you know it's
been some really really cool actually
I'll put a link in here so you can see
it and almost from the Lords of game
account check that out when you get a
chance so very proud of my team you know
with that and then um yeah check out
king of statues on White King David if
youhave it's a Marvel DC and all the
comics and stuff like that these
tremendous pieces he's doing and he also
gives you a synopsis for the character
if you don't if you don't know too much
about them different from like the
Marvel Universe Cinematic Universe check
that out and of course of the last word
first of all II got Real Talk man you're
my bro super proud super proud of you
man you have no idea how much your words
resonated with me super proud to call
you a friend and man you've touched a
soul today earlier today so I love to
look to you and our friendship and I
love what we do I love doing the show
with you I love working with you and
these are the reasons why and I put his
tweet out this is more than just a
podcast for me you're a friend and I'll
really enjoy work with you and these are
the reasons why I'm super proud to call
you a friend so thank you very much so
yeah I manage it
same to you it's like when I called and
talked for a long time mmm-hmm yeah it's
we are in a time that is at least in my
life unlike anything in history and you
know as I was just saying at the
beginning it's like all I can say is at
this point it shouldn't be for nothing
in it yes at this point it reads to be
the time that we all need to come
together for the right page and like
there is there is not to set there's a
right side of this there's not two sides
there's there's one proper side to be on
on this one and mmm I'm hoping with
enough like coming together and enough
like peaceful action done by the correct
people and yes getting the wrong people
out of power and all that type of
hopefully there can be some some change
to see or all of the things that are
wrong right now so absolutely brother I
agree I agree man could have said it
better like I said it any questions you
know reach out everybody you know you
got questions you don't know what to do
you look
helped you know ask someone ask someone
you know what could I do to help to try
to improve this situation because like
we said before you know the corporate
hashtag is cool you know that that's
cute you know there but we want action
but this cannot be in vain we have to
use this as a learning moment and a
teaching moment and to come together
we're all human beings you know I'm
saying they said this really affects
everyone this is a this is a DAT serious
an issue cuz this is this is police
brutality Suffolk's everybody so let's
do it man but you should look to the
chat for for rockin with us man super
proud of you guys you know we definitely
definitely wanted to get their message
across today so super proud yeah so I
mean on that I think that's where we're
gonna wrap this thing up I'm gonna send
you guys over to OB katie-cat definitely
give her some love this morning she's
kicking some butt I think working on
some night falls this morning if you
guys are listening on audio go check her
out she's an awesome streamer just so
many like rate helps and carries and
things she's really really cool OB ka TI
e ka t hmm go check her out I'm gonna
send you guys over there she's making a
partner push so always trying to send
big love that we can and as for
everybody in chat everybody out there in
the world whether you're driving around
in the car listen to this catching us
live all of these things take a second
let's see if we can make this a better
country to live in
absolutely brother absolutely so for
this episode 106 for the last word
fifth it's gonna be an interesting time
next week we've got our guests amazed
coming on
should be an awesome one next week to
chat about will be in the evening again
a reminder but that is basically all
we've got so for this episode it has
been the last word